let's go back actually now to the
Bahamas we mentioned that they were
slammed overnight by the force of
hurricane herma Nick Bryant also from
our partners at the BBC is in Nassau
Nick good morning good morning a
profound sense of relief here in the
Bahamas which didn't experience the
destructive power of Hurricane Irma that
was feared initially especially in the
central and northern parts of this
archipelago some outlying islands in the
south but did experience some structural
damage did experience some flooding but
nothing on the scale of what was
initially feared we're getting a sense
of the level of destruction elsewhere in
the Caribbean pabu do you remember that
was the first Island where hurricane
Irma made landfall 95 percent of the
buildings there have been destroyed that
Island has now been evacuated because of
the danger posed by hurricane Jose a
category 4 storm that's been barreling
across the Atlantic the US Virgin
Islands four deaths there have now been
confirmed the British Virgin Islands a
great deal of destruction especially in
the capital wrote am Dana Anthony back
to you Nick Bryant in Nassau and the
Bahamas where it appears they have at
least have dodged the the hit from Irma
but as we see heading our way and it
looks like a lot of people appear to the
evacuation yeah and I think seeing some
of that emptiness is eerie to some
people but we obviously are getting
people out and that is what Floridians
were told and warned to do at the
beginning of the week